I have a CN tower tattooed on my arm you
do I do I think cameras rolling cuz I
want this to be on camera see it yeah I
love it there are you really sentimental
right now this I don't have it but maybe
I'll get one so let's talk about now
apocalypse first question is what was
your parents reaction to the show I love
this question what do they say my dad's
an actor yeah he's he's you know as an
actor you kind of always have to juggle
with the idea of potentially playing a
game gay role and I've thought about it
and never really got presented the
opportunity and and I didn't and I loved
it with with no apocalypse and I wanted
to do it immediately and my boss
understands and he's like can't wait to
see it dude yeah he's my buddy
yeah he's proud of me and supports me
and so he's really excited yeah my yeah
my parents are very supportive and kind
of ease them into the show and didn't
tell them like all the details at first
I think I've let them onto more now
about what goes on in this crazy world
but yeah again like you know I've been
acting for quite a while now four years
and and there's always the chance your
daughter will be topless on TV so it's
they're very they're very cool they know
how much I love this project and they
know I wouldn't be doing this and
everything that comes with it if I
wasn't passionate about it it wasn't so
excited about and they see that so
they're they're very cool and yeah my
mom's like I'm dying to see it that's a
little more has a tip it's still very
yeah very cool about it so well it's an
edgy show but it's a fun show
it's a very honest show I think what's
fun is the whole like millennial la
aspect specifically the dating part you
know because I know like and that's my
question for you guys for dating are you
guys more of a new-school
have you been more of a new school at
type of person or you know squat I meet
you when I wear a me you I've done both
I think when it comes to dating I feel
like things are a little more
substantial when when you I'm pretty
picked picky with who I date yeah
and I want to be I want to know them for
a while so it's always like a friend
that I've known for a little while or
I'll try to go out on a couple of dates
with somebody who I meet on an app or I
have before and it doesn't always work
out but I'm not opposed to it I get it
Jesse you know I actually I've never
been on a dating app I want it let me
see
no I I would consider myself I guess
old-fashioned in that sense of meeting
so I don't know maybe it was just the
way my life worked out with
relationships I just was never on a
dating app but it's weird it takes us to
I don't know yeah I just kind of have
met people that more natural way I guess
I don't know yeah call me old-fashioned
you're old-fashioned I am you are Wow
so the roles are you guys are actors
playing roles of actors or people in you
know film and TV and in the show you
guys kind of talk about the audition
process and there's just like funny
moments that are very honest and and you
know other actors could really relate to
so I think my question is for you as
actors in real life what parts of your
role do you relate to playing an actor
mm-hmm did you relate in the aspect that
you know auditions are crazy yeah I
think it's a very appealing part of the
show because a lot of people in Los
Angeles I can relate so hard to it like
ourselves included yeah especially Carly
she plays a struggling actor we've all
been
and I like it it shows that's that's one
of her more vulnerable things with her
because she she is very confident in in
certain aspects of her life but that is
something that she's very hard on
herself about she's like my career sucks
and I can't book a job and I think it's
we've all had that feeling so it's it's
like it could happen I didn't anytime
Zoo
it's scary but it's it's kind of funny
it's ironic that I'm playing a
struggling actor on TV well being a
successful one
no it's it's just interesting in that
way and yeah everyone's everyone's been
there I think people will laugh too it's
like oh my gosh and I think there's a
scene I came up with which episode it is
but the whole first name of the episode
is like a montage of me in the audition
room with a casting director just being
so like outrageously terrible to me it's
the funniest thing I've ever seen in my
life so again I think a lot of people
will relate to that maybe not like quite
that level but still just so like yep
mmhmm yeah seven relatable she's got a
moment where she has a nod she's
rehearsing her audition with yeah what
were you doing an audition with a guy I
don't know alright yeah was hidden
lesson Farah now she's a cam girl with
these with this show it's like can we
talk about this sensitive stuff ya know
what the hell I want to say but she has
an audition that she needs to rehearse
for but she's working she's being a cam
girl and then the guy that she's doing
it with us like I'll do anything for you
and she's like let me do this audition
and that can really help me like
memorize my lines it's a very funny
moment really funny that's struggle like
I'm doing anything I can to succeed here
like it's just it's so funny yeah I
definitely relate to that